wir haben gerade wirklich wieder
eindrucksvoll gehört und das tun wir
jeden tag wie ernsthaft dieser
auseinandersetzungen oder dieser
angriffsweg russlands ist und wir
bekommen auch mit was das für folgen hat
für unsere sanktionen die wir vollends
unterstützen und die auch auf lange
sicht weiter durchgehalten werden müssen
natürlich bedeutet das dass wir in
deutschland höhere rohstoffpreise haben
weil wir und das sind außenpolitische
einschätzungen die in der vergangenheit
gemacht wurden eine zu große
abhängigkeit bei energieträgern von
russland entwickelt haben deswegen wäre
ja auch schrittweise rausholen dennoch
kann man die menschen mit diesen
spritpreise nicht alleine lassen und
deswegen bin ich sehr froh dass unser
bundesfinanzminister dazu einen sehr
konkreten vorschlag gemacht hat wie wir
die menschen entlassen können entlasten
können ich kann natürlich nicht genau
sagen wie hoch da sein wird und wann das
beginnt aber es ist das
schnellstmögliche wir haben das wirklich
sehr genau geprüft und ich freue mich
sehr dass dieser vorschlag jetzt auf dem
tisch liegt und natürlich auch die
diskussion
ja da muss ich antworten denn damit habe
ich nicht gehört
haben wir zwei stränge der eine strang
ist die energie wir haben den schock
durch den krieg den spüren wir jeden tag
nicht nur das natürlich auch durch die
zulieferung von teilen die lieferketten
unterbrochen sind das vor allem auch für
die automobilindustrie als eine ganz
harte zeit ist die bänder stehen still
die leute gehen in kurzarbeit und dann
kommen sie nach hause und haben auch
noch die erhöhten energie-preise da ist
das paket des geschnürt wurde von dieser
ampel koalition von dieser
bundesregierung zu klein und auf der
jetzt aktuellen seite dieser rabatt
vorschlag von christian lindner da muss
ich einfach sagen der ist viel zu kurz
gesprungen und auch viel zu kompliziert
also die fdp hat sich immer
aufgeschaukelt als eine
entbürokratisierung partei ich kann mich
erinnern bei der pflicht für den neckar
und von vielen anderen mittelständischen
betrieben hat die fdp eigene kampagne
gemacht jetzt macht sie dasselbe für
mich ist entscheidend dass es beim
preisschild darum geht wenn man 100
tankstelle vorbei fährt dass die anzeige
den warenpreis wiedergibt ich bin im
grenzraum wo viel tanktourismus momentan
zu österreich ist da ist entscheidend
was
dort ausgewiesen ist als preis da fährt
nicht einer hin und schaut dann und
sorgt welchen rabatt bekomme ich dann
tanke ich das rein dann gehe ich zum
tankwart dann sage ich bitte bitte ich
habe meine karten sowie sony dabei die
die bankkarten ja das kommt noch
erschwerend hinzu dann kriege ich noch
ein rabatt und der
tankstellenbetreiber soll dann mit dem
finanzminister abrechnen da ist scheint
hatten sie denn natürlich natürlich ja
natürlich und deswegen weiß ich habe im
unterschied zum bundeskanzler was der
liter sprit kostet im moment ja im
durchschnitt 230 also da ist sogar da
diese jetzt noch kräuter durch die
heizöl abfragen viermal so hoch wie
sonst sieht man dass die leute in panik
sind und dementsprechend es ist ganz
einfach schlagen sie von der
ampelkoalition etwas vor in dieser woche
und mir machen 40 cent günstiger dann
kommen wir unter die 2 euro und wie
erreichen wir das erste reduzierung der
energiesteuern zweitens reduzierung der
mehrwertsteuer drittens eine erhöhte
beimischungsquote für biokraftstoffe
dann helfen wir nicht nur den
privatsektor sondern vor allem auch dem
gewerbe vor allem dem speditionsgewerbe
uns darf nicht passieren dass die
lieferketten unterbrochen werden uns
darf nicht passieren dass 47.000
unternehmen in der speditions und
logistikbranche die selber auf dem hof
beim logistikzentrum meistens betriebs
tankstellen haben dass diese speditionen
ihren betrieb einstellen müssen weil sie
die preise nicht mehr weitergeben können
und die legal regale leer sind da wäre
dann die ampel dafür verantwortlich für
diese leeren regale und das will ich
nicht dass wenn ein ehrliches angebot
diese woche abstimmen können wir sofort
wissen wie teuer er schreie ich kann es
ihnen richtig sie wurden dann selbst so
oft mit forderungen zu ballern eines
verkehrs- und setzten sie auf den sitzen
und schöne ja aber wie
glaubwürdig weil ich habe nämlich vor
der bundestagswahl am 6.9 die spritpreis
bremse gefordert dass über
ja auch absehbar also herr kollege sie
sind noch sehr jung dabei im bundestag
aber sechster neunter 2021 war vor der
bundestagswahl ja aber da war ja schon
1000 waren da war ich ja kommen da war
ich im gleichschritt mit dem
fdp vorsitzende linda der hat die
spritpreis bremse aufgefordert ich kann
es nachweisen schauen sie bei bild
erfahren auch im archiv und am 13 10
habe ich nochmal nach der wald ist
gefordert wenn er über die zwei euro
geht und jetzt könnte glaubwürdig sein
christian lindner könnte glaubwürdig
sein und bei der spritpreis bremse sowie
die von der union vorgeschlagen mit man
erwirbt aber keine glaubwürdigkeit bei
den menschen wenn man eu rechtswidrige
vorschläge macht und die dann umsetzen
und die werden dann wieder kassiert also
ich weiß sie haben oft eine andere
rechtsauffassung als der ogh aber sie
wissen selbst die mehrwertsteuer in
deutschland die kann nicht mal eben
ermäßigt werden denn die
mehrwertsteuersystem richtlinie regelt
in anhang 3 und artikel 102 auf welche
produkte der ermäßigte satz wir waren
auch ein grantler wegen corona gemacht
warum haben es bei gastro kalt da um
lebens- oder die geht und die sind und
die sind in anhang 3 aufgeführt also da
gehen sie die nummern durch das ist sehr
sehr leicht das zu fordern wenn man es
aber nicht rechtskonform macht dann wird
es am ende wieder kassiert und deswegen
sage ich ja gerade wir können auch
gleich noch mal über die energie steuer
sprechen wir haben uns das sehr genau
angeschaut wir haben sehr genau auch
gerechnet was hat am ende welche
auswirkungen und wir können nie
garantieren dass die rohstoffpreise sich
nicht wieder so erhöhen dass das
eingeholt wird also das sind
weltmarktpreise und deswegen muss man
erstens aufpassen dass das geld auch an
die menschen zurück kommt und nicht
irgendwo ölmultis oder so versinkt und
andererseits muss man es
eu-rechtskonform machen ich bin auch
dafür und ein bisschen enttäuscht dass
man das auf eu ebene sehen wir gerade
gesagt ich bin noch jung da lernt man
noch einiges dass man das auf eu ebene
nicht so einfach mal machen kann und
gerade in der notsituation würde ich mir
da mehr flexibilität wünschen wir müssen
aber jetzt konkret mit dem arbeiten was
wir haben und da sagen wir 20 30 cent je
nachdem dieser vorschlag von christian
lindner ist ja auch eigentlich x core
plus weil christian das schöne daran
gemacht 15 cent machen wir ja 20 cent
deswegen müssen wir doch eigentlich
sagen sind nun mal besser als die
franzosen jahre aber da muss man schon
dazusagen der preis für einen liter
sprit in frankreich ist momentan unter
zwei euro nämlich 197 die haben ein ganz
anderes
steuerniveau wir sind weit über dem
mindeststeuer satz den die eu vorgibt
und deswegen wundere ich mich gerade
weil dann hat er christian lindner im
wahlkampf nach ihrer these was europa
rechtswidriges gemacht jetzt sage ich
ihnen wissen sie
dieser vorschlag ist ja schnell gekommen
weil letzte woche hat der christian
lindner gesagt es wird noch gar nichts
gemacht jetzt heute warten wir auf mit
einem neuen vorschlag einem mini rabatt
und sofort in derselben sekunde
widerspricht spd und grüne das ist doch
chaos mensch machen wir doch einfach in
dieser woche ein klares signal der
entlastung für die bürgerinnen und
bürger mit den stimmen der union wenn es
in die richtige richtung geht nämlich
die drei punkte die ich angesprochen hat
gesagt dass wir gar nicht wollen naja
ich ihn verstehen glaube ich dem wetter
gerade noch einmal ob ich finde es total
schön dass sich politiker weil verfahren
streiten wir normalerweise sind selber
die großen visionen ich sehe den
unterschiedlichsten nicht noch nicht so
ganz ist das ganze jetzt nur ein
unterbietungswettbewerb sozusagen am
meisten
cent auf den tisch legen kann oder wo
liegt eigentlich der unterschied also
wenn ich meiner mutter jetzt erklären
muss das eine oder das andere
dass das wäre das richtige wo ist der
unterschied waren ja wirklich und das
ist wirklich wichtig dass man es konkret
vielleicht mal kurz auf dröselt weil das
ein wirkliches problem ist was ich auch
generell in deutschland sehe was man
auch mal langfristig angehen könnte aber
jetzt müssen wir kurzfristig an der
benzin diesel preis der bildet sich in
deutschland zu einem großen teil nicht
aus dem rohstoff preis sondern aus einer
energie steuerlich bestritt beträgt man
benzin 65 cent bei diesel 47 aus der
mehrwertsteuer jetzt noch co2 preis also
da gibt es sehr konkrete ansätze die man
fahren kann natürlich wir wollen wir
nicht weltmarktpreise subventionieren
aber wenn wir es dann recht sicher für
die menschen auch machen wollen dann
müssen wir es sehr konkret und auch sehr
rechtskonform umsetzen denn ansonsten
verlieren die menschen noch mehr
vertrauen und diese aussetzung der
energie steuer ich habe gerade setzte
genannt wir sind uns einig wir wollen
nicht die staatseinnahmen völlig leer
laufen lassen sagen wir mal wie wir
setzen das aus dann sinkt der
benzinpreis um akut 65 cent finde ich
ganz interessante idee hatte ich auch
diskutieren aber was ist wenn wir die
wieder einsetzen dann ist der staat
verantwortlich für 65 cent plus der
nordost und jörg ich habe keine angst
also 72 60
dollar fielen und ihrer mutter sehr sehr
einfach erklären beim herr linder steht
weiterhin der spritpreis auf der anzeige
nämlich zwei euro 30 ist zum tanken
tanks gehst rein und holte mit diesem es
einen rabatt vom tankwart der wiederum
abrechnet dann später diesen rabatt mit
dem finanz das geht ja übrigens nicht
über eine schublade voller bonbons also
wunderjahr die csu gearbeitet habe aber
das geht schon auch sogar
das ist ihre variante unsere variante
ist las dem preis oben stehen an der
straße mit dem reduzierten
steuerminderung betrag über
energiesteuern über mehrwertsteuer mit
einer erhöhten beimischungsquote und die
steuerfreiheit dann hätten wir auch noch
was fürs klima getan und dann zahlst du
einfach diese
197 an der zapfsäule und du brauchst nur
tanken zahlen wieder gehen und nichts
für die scheibe freuen wir uns jetzt in
die in die debatte über die technik noch
weiter beleben ich finde es aber auch
sehr spannend würde ich gerne einmal in
spa wonsheimer nochmal aus kiew eine
etwas übergeordnete frage stellen paul
die sich ja auch viele deutsche fragen
und blick auf die steigenden preise
energiepreise du hast eben schon das
öl-embargo angesprochen müssen wir
deutschen für die schweiz zahlen du bist
vor ort
in gewisser weise
tragen wir natürlich konsequenzen
unseres moralischen handelns ist wäre
eine lüge zu sagen das ist nicht der
fall
aber man musste ich diese frage eben
glaube ich viel größer stellen als
einfach zu sagen machen wir das jetzt
weil in der ukraine krieg herrscht am
ende geht es um unsere werte auch um
unsere freiheit und vor allem um die
frage was könnte wladimir putin als
nächstes tun was tut er wenn er hier in
der ukraine erfolg hat greift er dann
ein nato land an
lucie lenski hat in einem der interviews
mit ihm geführt hat gesagt wer weiß
vielleicht steht ja irgendwann in ost
berlin das mag jetzt der eine oder
andere zuschauer die eine und andere
zuschauerin für völlig verrückt halten
aber viele hier oder viel in deutschland
haben auch mich und andere für verrückt
erklärt als ich gesagt habe es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass bald krieg um kiew
geführt wird und dass darüber reden wir
schon viele jahre von daher ist bei
wladimir putin ganz generell gar nichts
mehr ausgeschlossen
wenn wir uns die benzinpreis diskussion
anhören dann finde ich sehr wichtig dass
die geführt wird denn ist es natürlich
einfach für jemanden wie mich der ein
sehr gutes gehalt hat zusagen frieren
wir die für die freiheit und und dinge
wie das ja das ist etwas wo man eben mit
den menschen sprechen muss die weniger
geld im portemonnaie haben und vor allem
muss die politik ihnen helfen dass es
einen sozialen ausgleich gibt denn ich
glaube das schlimmste und ich bewerte
ist ja ganz bewusst auch von hier aus
der ukrainischen perspektive wäre wenn
dadurch eine
soziale explosion entsteht in
deutschland so will ich es einmal nennen
leute die hütten sind weil sie die zeche
zahlen müssen und dann sich die wut auf
die ukraine und lädt das wäre etwas was
wir unbedingt verhindern müssen und
deswegen finde ich diese diskussion
wahnsinnig wichtig und vor allem egal da
bin ich jetzt nicht im technischen so
drin aber egal in welcher form und ich
glaube ganz besonders wichtig ist dass
es schnell passiert